[Aplausos]
[Música]
nós viemos não caracteriza quem somos e
como nos caracteriza
é o que e como fazê los
eu vender minha casa onde tudo e todos
dependemos da outra margem da cidade que
é que está lá quase nada acontece
eu sou professor de profissão apaixonado
pela fotografia a fotografia é que fez a
minha mãe tomar força
foi através da metamorfose que
transformou a minha forma de pensar a
vida e de ver o mundo
há tempos atrás na ilha de água só
tenhamos média dos três fotógrafos para
fazer a foto tenha que ter um número
significativo para depois passar para a
outra margem cada cidade para fazer para
selecionar as fotos
e sabe qual é o tipo de barco não
usávamos barco à vela no processo de ida
das fotos de volta das forças às tantas
encontramos com intempéries do tempo num
mar as águas
as fotos teriam sido outra se molhava
nem sei lá acontecia nem chegava produto
associado a minha paixão pela fotografia
pensei em te vi que era um estúdio
fotográfico
tudo isso tudo fotográfica é tem muitos
custos mas criei a minha maneira
[Aplausos]
não é um estudo convencional com vocês
aqui da cidade
aquele estudo fotográfico dêem água não
é tudo aí mas só passava avelar foto
terá um forte lá lá lá estava tudo bem
imagina a acontecer um dia ela é uma
ilha
tá sempre há tempo para mudar é uma
grande tempestade acompanhada com chuva
então a ver aquele coqueiro ali lado ali
bc do dia no tempo de tempestade
caio ramos do coqueiro na chapa de 5 aí
tá chapas e bill
toda a água da chuva entrou lá as
máquinas ficarão na largada quando
cheguei no dia seguinte eu ao game o fim
quando fazia shows não sabe abrir a
máquina não sabe nada nem ariadne
máquinas fotográficas e operar as
máquinas todas a com abas
eu pensei mas uma fossa velho dentro de
mim motivadora jorge abrantes martins
eu não sei quando vou abrir as matas
fechadas
acordei no processo e fazer fotografias
para a grécia pode ficar em termos de
usar de hora para acordar com a ponta
dessa visão após a briga os magros
experimentei funcionou abrir as máquinas
o primeiro obstáculo ultrapassado tem de
limpar as matas mas não chegavam como o
câncer
lembrete em casa tem secador usam para
fazer cabelo e deus acabando o cabelo
comecei a assoprar nas máquinas como
será quente e secaram
vamos pra fechar e abrir essa festa é
difícil perdeu tempo até conseguir
imaginar ginástica mas acabei consegui
outro desafio vamos liberar as máquinas
têm medo senão vão explodir o que
ligares máquinas sabiá valeu as máquinas
me surpreenderam funcionará normalmente
[Aplausos]
foi a partir daí onde pensei você
imagina a transpassar mulher nem nada
nem a tudo depende da cidade mesmo a
falar foi quando ganhei aqui basta ter
fãs vão ter um bocadinho de água tem que
mandar para a cidade
o telefone tem problema domingo tem que
mandar para a cidade de cortês eu
consegui abrir minhas máquinas com
tesoura
fechei voltar a funcionar porque não
compra a chave de telefones e eu começar
a abrir fonte é que nem nada
[Aplausos]
congregados na cidade praiana naquele
estudo a nossa maneira
já passava estudo preparação de mofo
definir formas ao país confiável reparar
o erro conseguir reparar peguei para
vender aproveitar essa senhora há
sensivelmente ao ver bem aqueles tudo
ali é um mix ali a lira para esse
telefone vendem material escolar e
tirasse pop há porque nós não tem nada
tudo depende de outra março mas o que me
tirou da iata para vir aqui nesse para o
que deves não ande capô horas a iata
prazeres contar uma história dele quem
não queremos jogar bem
[Aplausos]
eu estou aqueles pagos para incentivar
quem pretende ser empreendedor
para ser empreendedor não é fácil
o empreendedor tem que ser persistente
empreendedor ao ver dificuldade em
procurar soluções
foi através dessas funções que a pane
nas dificuldades que foi empreendendo no
emprego em prêmios
isto é eu comecei sem saber a fazer
alguma coisa mas aprender fazendo fazer
quando disse mais que os meus para
escolher por contar aqueles pago aqui
foi através da minha coragem que bush
estou aqui disparou aqui
eu dei muito mais na nossa ilha agora
chama-se sofrem de fotografias já
seguido de jorge fotos na nossa ilha já
não se sofre estão gravação do telefone
imaginar você é sair de uma bebidinha
data acabar 4 ordem para viver na cidade
de reparar telefone ou até imaginar saiu
de iata com seu filho para a cidade para
virar fotos de meu corpo para a escola
era um sofrimento mas tudo isso já não
acontece
[Aplausos]
é que os estou aqui com a minha tanna
fotográfica já existe momento histórico
da minha ilha já existe um momento
histórico da cadete batizado casamento
da minha e já não se perde porque temos
tudo lá nem água
no nosso estudo a moda em água é através
da minha coragem que os quem a casa saiu
para o continente e para o mundo
e eu digo meu limite é o céu
[Aplausos]